Curious if the mud wig protocol is valuable, or how do you do it if you are restricting
daring?
We've got this question a lot.
I think the mud wig protocol can be valuable, but I have some people doing the mud wig
protocol because it tested on them with cheek swab test.
But can you do the mud wig protocol if you're not supposed to be taking dairy?
And my answer to that is no, you can't do the mud wig protocol if you're restricting
daring.
Now, if on your cheek swab test, I just put limit dairy, then we should have a specific
conversation whether I think that would be okay for you to do if you feel led to do that.
But if on your cheek swab test it says no dairy, then I would say let's not do the mud wig
protocol right there.
Now, if you talked to mud wig, I've said this before, if you went on their website, it
says that the oil changes the dairy.
There is it's a magical thing that goes on when you add a flaxseed oil to dairy and blend
it up.
It still has the qualities of stimulating growth.
It still has IGF1, it still stimulates the pathways that could stimulate growth.
So I would say no, it doesn't make those changes.